[Musica]
se 23 anni fa mi avessero offerto di
partecipare un viaggio difficile e molto
complesso ma affascinante ed
estremamente bello ma perché mi avrebbe
permesso di vedere luoghi e cose che non
avrei mai potuto vedere forse avrei
accettato
buongiorno buongiorno a tutti
il mio viaggio però è iniziato senza che
io potessi decidere
mi sono accorto che ero in viaggio
perché non avevo mai niente via da
raccontare di mio figlio
tutti i genitori dei coetanei di mio
figlio avevano ogni giorno qualcosa da
raccontare di loro figlio e io non avevo
mai niente pensate ero terrorizzato che
prima o poi qualcuno mi dicesse che suo
figlio avevo iniziato a volare e io mai
niente e lì che io e mia moglie abbiamo
capito che eravamo partiti per un
viaggio ma non sapevamo dove saremmo
andati non conoscevamo neppure la strada
che dovevamo fare
eravamo in un tunnel buio dal quale ci
sembrava impossibile uscire il primo
lampo utile a capire dove ci trovavamo è
stata paradossalmente la diagnosi
abbiamo capito in quel momento che non
era colpa nostra ma quel lampo è durato
molto poco e subito dopo ci siamo
accorti che il nostro bambino ideale
quello che cullandolo appena nato
avevamo fatto un film intero della sua
della sua vita beh quello non c'era più
era morto nei pochi istanti in cui si
pronuncia la parola autismo quel bambino
era morto per vedete per tutte le altre
famiglie e bambini ideale muore ma muore
lentamente perché non è proprio la
medaglia alle olimpiadi ma è il
campionato parrocchiale non è proprio la
migliore università non sono proprio i
migliori voti ma non ce ne accorgiamo
muore lentamente invece per noi il
nostro bambino ideale è morto in quei
pochi istanti
ne è nato un alto estremamente
affascinante e che era in grado di
donarci delle soddisfazioni enormi ma
ancora noi non lo sapevamo
e quindi abbiamo incominciato ad
affrontare il nostro tunnel un pochino
più consapevoli e abbiamo incominciato a
cercare informazioni e abbiamo scoperto
alcune cose ad esempio che le persone
con autismo vivono una realtà molto
diversa perché i loro sensi forniscono
informazioni differenti dalle persone
senza autismo e quindi sono seduti di
fianco a noi ma vivono in altre realtà
le persone con autismo hanno difficoltà
a comunicare la loro percezione e le
persone con autismo vivono il tempo in
maniera molto differente dalle persone
senza autismo insomma nostro figlio
stava facendo un'altra gara non dovevamo
più confrontarlo con i coetanei perché
lui stava facendo un'altra gara e in
questa gara non vince chi arriva prima
vince chi crea la persona migliore e
quindi persa la il confronto con i
coetanei cominciavamo a vedere i suoi
miglioramenti e non erano pochi e
finalmente abbiamo incominciato a vivere
insieme a lui ma capite queste cose ci
sembrava ovvio di evitargli qualunque
tipo di problema
eravamo noi a decidere cosa gli andava
bene cosa non gli andava bene e quindi
se gli dava fastidio il supermercato
evitavamo il supermercato in realtà
stavamo costruendo un mattone su mattone
una prigione al nostro figlio perché
poteva anche diventare ingegnere
nucleare ma se non si sa fare la spesa
lui doveva essere assistito tutta la
vita e quindi capito che non era il
problema di tommaso ma purtroppo eravamo
noi genitori a essere il limite di
nostro figlio eravamo noi che avevamo
una paura quella di impattare la società
allora abbiamo incominciato a abbattere
la nostra paura e abbiamo incominciato
ad uscire
l'impatto con la società insieme al
nostro figlio con autismo è stata la
difficoltà più grossa che abbiamo
affrontato difficilissimo
difficilissimo e abbiamo capito che era
necessario pensare a un insieme di
informazioni da divulgare a tutte le
persone in maniera che la nostra vita di
familiari e la vita di nostro figlio
fosse migliore una qualità di vita
migliore
nasce così l'idea di un accoglienza
consapevole di poter diffondere una
vasta platea un insieme di informazioni
che servissero ad accogliere meglio le
persone con autismo e le loro famiglie
da questa idea ne ho fatto un'impresa ma
se incominciò a fare un bilancio del mio
viaggio che sta continuando all'interno
del mondo dell'autismo
penso che adesso vedo solo cose positive
vedete l'autismo di mio figlio oggi mi
ha permesso di essere su questo palco ed
è una cosa incredibile guardarmi credete
e l'autismo di mio figlio mi ha permesso
dire di fare il lavoro che mi piace
l'autismo di mio figlio analizzando
l'enrico del prima dell'autismo e
l'enrico del dopo autismo mi ha reso una
persona migliore
l'autismo di mio figlio ha reso una
tutta la mia famiglia l'autismo di mio
figlio è stata la molla per partire per
il nostro viaggio ed è un viaggio
fantastico ora cosa
cos'è importante è importante pensare
che queste cose positive possono essere
messe a disposizione di tutti
lei limite il limite che molte persone
si girano dall'altra parte non vogliono
guardare in realtà basta poco perché
l'autismo ti permette di acquisire delle
delle informazioni e degli skill
importantissimi per il mondo del lavoro
per me è stato importantissimo nel mondo
del lavoro perché oggi le aziende creano
gruppi di lavoro eterogenei con realtà e
provenienza
diverse perché punti di vista differenti
creano idee migliori
bene l'autismo aiuta le persone a
superare un livello tale di difficoltà
di comunicazione che permette poi di
diventare dei grandi comunicatori
permette di essere dei team builder
fantastici e quei gruppi di lavoro
eterogenei delle aziende hanno bisogno
di un disabile diversi team manager e le
persone che hanno avuto un'esperienza
con una persona con autismo è un diversi
team manager fantastico dunque dobbiamo
smettere di girarci dall'altra parte ma
non lo facciamo per le persone con
autismo
lo facciamo per noi non lo facciamo per
le persone con autismo perché le persone
con autismo dalla vostra vicinanza
possono cambiare poco la loro vita ma le
persone con autismo possono dare a voi
il modo di diventare delle persone
migliori di diventare quelle persone che
hanno acquisito uno skill che nessun
libro né subito nessun insegnante vi
potrà mai dare allora lo fate solo per
voi no lo fate anche per integrare nella
società le persone con autismo le
persone con autismo possono essere
attive possono essere membri della
nostra società a tutti gli effetti non
sono un mondo a parte sono parte del
nostro mondo perché ci danno un punto di
vista radicalmente diverso dal nostro
e questo è molto importante
e allora cosa facciamo se accogliete le
persone con autismo diventate
protagonisti di un mondo migliore e
abbiamo bisogno di persone che rendono
il mondo migliore e non lo facciano per
fare del bene lo fanno perché hanno un
obiettivo preciso devono migliorare la
propria persona e questo vi porterà a
migliorare il mondo
allora tutti insieme mi raccomando non
evitate le persone con autismo
non lasciate a casa le persone con
autismo e invitate le ai compleanni dei
vostri figli perché le persone con
autismo sono parte della nostra società
e voi potrete ottenere da questo da
questa esperienza delle soddisfazioni
enormi veramente per me l'autismo è la
cosa più bella che mi è capitata nella
vita e vi auguro che lo diventi anche
per voi
[Musica]